marg range ash sorry hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp
welcome to another edition of my what I
eat in a day youtuber review so this
week I'm going to be reviewing Carolyn
dessler's new what I you today nothing
till four healthy vegan plus workout
video a mouthful and there's
unfortunately not much going in her
mouth but let's talk about it because
this woman is doing both vegan diet and
intermittent fasting at the same time
I'm already feeling hungry but honestly
it feels like every single time I watch
one of these youtubers videos it seems
like their window of eating just keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
now if you've already watched one of my
videos on intrument fasting you probably
kind of already know my sentiments here
but if you have not watched it I highly
suggest that you check it out right here
to give yourself a little bit of a
refresher but after that check this out
I'm gonna talk about her diet so let's
do this
it wouldn't be a vegan youtubers what I
eat in a day video without the token
green juice and a big portion of that
honestly I'm all for greens I'm so happy
that she's getting her greens here in
the morning but it doesn't have to be
such a huge huge portion and there's no
fiber there when you have it in juice
not to mention like is a four o'clock
there yet because like I'm not
advocating for her to not eat anything
till four o'clock but the title says
nothing till four stop lying
Carolyn so that looks like a pretty
awesome workout I would totally be down
for that but I am not sure that I would
have the energy on just green juice
alone and yes there is some research to
suggest that working out fasted may
slightly boost your fat burning
potential simply because you burn
through your sugar stores and then you
burn into your fat but you can also burn
into your muscle not to mention the
research in this area is not that strong
and some studies have actually found no
difference between working out fasted
and not fasted personally I know I do
best with a little bit of fuel in my
tank just to give me some energy so that
I don't burn out and then I get home
from the gym and I'm like super hanging
and I just want to put everything into
my face not to mention post-workout you
know the best thing to do to to really
kind of fuel those muscles to build that
muscle mass is of course to ensure
you're getting some protein and some
carbohydrates to refuel those sugar
stores and to feed those hungry muscles
not sure we're gonna see that here with
Carolyn either so poor hungry muscles so
giving you guys a little body update
yeah I've been eating a bit more fat in
the last few months and I have gained a
little weight but yeah I feel amazing
that is all that matters so I like that
she's talking about her body in a
positive way even when it comes to
weight gain and she's talking about the
importance of eating more fat and that's
great because fat is awesome and you
know there's lots of great healthy fats
like things in like avocados and nuts
and seeds all of which are so important
and beneficial to our health they help
support our energy levels insulate our
important organs improve our immune
system great for cardiovascular health
so I like that she kind of threw that in
there as well I want a vacation so
beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so nothing to eat yet still
just another drink we've got some green
powder supplement in some water and I
have no qualms about you know green
supplements they're a great way to kinda
pack in some nutrition for those days
where you're a little low on the fruits
and veggies but I mean as we're gonna
see when Carolyn actually starts to eat
that's not her problem what I would love
to see is her incorporate some protein
and some real calories into her day so
let's take a look at what's coming next
[Applause]
ding ding ding ding ding yay it's eating
time I am like more excited for her than
she probably is so let's take a look at
what she's eating what what okay let's
just like back it up here girl because
I'm minute ago I was trying to give you
some props for like not criticizing
yourself for gaining weight but now
you're saying that on days that you wear
a bikini you purposefully choose not to
eat you purposefully choose to limit
your eating to just four to five hours
the fact that you're saying that is so
so dangerous because now we have all
these girls who are watching this video
thinking that on days that they want to
wear a bikini and lay on the beach that
they probably shouldn't eat at all
I'm pissed
[Music]
well I am glad that it's working for
Carolyn but I want people to know that
this diet is not necessarily for
everyone a lot of people cite things
like headaches or difficulty
concentrating or digestive issues as
possible side effects I mean especially
if we're just talking about eating for
four to five hours in the day and so my
opinion is that if you're hungry your
body's telling you something and the
best thing that you can do is respond by
feeding it not by eating by some
arbitrary rules that some youtubers set
up for you
[Music]
and also at work blog I feel like I
enjoy my meal more because it's not
something for thought like you wake up
and you're tired whoa back it up girl
honestly food is not meant to be earned
this confessional here has all the
markings and red flags of an eating
disorder and I am getting seriously
concerned as a professional so this is
what I'm having
so I basically always travel with a big
Tupperware glass box I just put this in
my luggage or I have it with me on the
flight so I pack all the fruits from the
breakfast in there and it also had a bit
more so I keep this in the fridge it's
nice fresh and cold I still have one
green juice so I'm gonna drink that
first that's a lot of fruit and not much
else
I love fruit there's lots of vitamins
minerals and antioxidants that a lot of
people don't really get enough of but
that's a lot of sugar and not a lot of
fiber because especially she's choosing
kind of like the lower fiber fruits
there she got melon and banana and mango
that are all just really high in sugar
and low in fiber plus where's the
protein and those healthy fats that she
was talking about earlier I would love
to see a little bit more balance here in
her meal especially because she's really
not eating much in the day just the
quickest so you want to have that first
so basically you want to eat your way up
start with the fruits that they just you
see it and the watermelon is basically
just 90% water so so yes that is mainly
water but also like a lot of sugar and
not a lot else and so when she was
saying that you want to start with the
watermelon first because of the
digestive issues there is some truth to
this because when we fast for a longer
period of time we see our digestive
enzymes slow or even halt in production
so the idea is you don't want to start
like with a really big heavy
Neal you want to give yourself a little
bit of time to adjust to those meals to
to build up those digestive enzymes
again so starting with something
easygoing like watermelon might be a
good idea but I don't really think there
would be much of a difference in
starting with the mango or the banana
because all of these are really low
fiber high sugar fruits so he basically
eat all the honey melon from the bow
then I go to the pineapple papaya and
mangoes and also gonna have a few
bananas so I never count calories I know
you guys are very interested in it so
I'm gonna basically just tell you how
many calories it has but I never counted
and I just eat what feels right for me
seriously I'm totally on board with that
philosophy this is really at the core of
intuitive and mindful eating and I love
that I'm all about eating in ways the
health has become our healthiest
happiest self however knowing Carolyn's
super strict diet I can't say that
anything she's doing is particularly
intuitive I mean I can't say for sure
how Carolyn is feeling physically or
emotionally but I do know that being so
vigilant and religious with your diet
rules tends to take a psychological tool
I know I wouldn't feel my best on a
punishing regime like this oh god more
green juice girl how much green juice
can you drink I mean I love veggies I
want you to have all the veggies but I
weigh rather see her like eat the
cucumber and the celery and I don't know
I guess she said ginger or whatever else
is in there maybe with some avocado in
there some hummus to get a little bit of
protein and healthy fats like switch it
up girl you can chew you got teeth you
got a mouth let's do this
[Music]
oh my god finally the woman's having a
little bit of protein and fat in those
nuts oh I'm happy about that we've got
some Omega threes we got some fiber some
protein all I hear are things in one
little package snack that's awesome
much more satiating than all the other
things that I've seen her consume in the
day which just really be not that much
so Thank You Carolyn I'm feeling a
little more satisfied myself now dinner
is ready so I'm going to show you what
I'm having
this is just pure greens and I wanted I
can wrap all the veggies in the green so
make like some little nicer brats here I
got some baked sweet potatoes again you
know oil and salt
[Music]
this meal is really really confusing me
I mean there's just a lot of carbs
there's no protein again we're missing
out on the protein I'm sad about that
and one thing I really don't get is that
she was talking specifically about not
having any oil on her sweet potatoes I
don't understand that because earlier
she was talking about making sure she
was getting more of fats in the day not
to mention a lot of people may not
realize this but fat is so important
because it increases the absorption of
fat soluble vitamins so really it's a
missed opportunity not to have a little
bit of fat when it comes to your salads
or if you're having a lot of fruits or
vegetables in your meal girl just throw
a little bit of olive oil in there maybe
just kind of beef it up a bit it'll
taste so much better not to mention that
you're gonna get so much more out of
your meal so let's break down Carolyn's
diet now there is nothing wrong with a
vegan diet or even a predominately raw
vegan diet like Carolyn seems to mostly
follow
however Carolyn's version is really
really unbalanced she's getting about 50
servings of fruits and vegetables in the
day and not really much else there's not
a lot of protein not a lot of fat and
there's not really any grains or
anything like that going in there so I
am a bit concerned because yes fruits
and vegetables are so important and the
vast majority of people are not getting
enough of them but there's also so much
value in getting a wide range of foods
into your day
even if you are following a vegan diet
all right so based on our nutrition
calculations
Caroline's actually getting more
calories than she puts up on the screen
so we are estimating her at about 20 472
calories where she suggests she's eating
18:50 it's possible that there are some
foods that she just didn't include in
the calculations and that's where the
discrepancies lie but you know in terms
of recommendations for an active female
at her age the recommendations is around
2,400 calories so she is doing pretty
well when it comes to calories despite
the fact that she's not saying she's
counting calories as for her
macronutrient distribution things are
really off kilter so we are estimating
that Carolyn's getting 73% of her
calories from carbs 20% of her calories
from fat and just 7% of her calories
from protein of those carbs Carolyn is
getting about 303 grams of sugar ah yes
a lot of that is coming from like
healthy fruits and fruits and vegetables
but still that is a lot of sugar
she's also only getting about 47 grams
of protein some from the veggies and
some from the nuts but because she's
exercising and doing intermittent
fasting I would definitely be worried
about muscle loss or at the very least
just like not optimizing her workouts
very well I did a little bit of extra
research and I found that Carolyn does
not like a lot of vegan processed foods
like tofu but there are so many other
great sources of vegan protein like
beans legumes quinoa lentils and hemp
seeds okay so next I want to talk about
some inconsistencies in the video so the
video is called nothing till 4 but I'm
pretty sure she was drinking green juice
like sometime in the morning and that
has calories and sugar in it and is not
necessarily allowed while doing
intermittent fasting during your fasting
period now digging through some of the
comments here she see she was replying
that she was jet-lagged and it was noon
in London and she normally eats sometime
between noon and 2:00 but she was also
saying that she only eats at a four to
five hour window while on vacation it's
also confusing and it's really not
making sense
bottom line is it didn't really look
like she was only eating in a 4 to 5
hour window so that's definitely
something to consider as a viewer as
well also this girl talks a lot about
mindfulness and promoting mindful eating
but then she talks about earning her
meals which is definitely not mindful
eating or intuitive in my books at all I
definitely would say this would not work
for most people
and while Carolyn may feel great on this
diet I worry about the rationale behind
this regime to all my viewers watching
at home please know that this is not the
only way to live a healthy lifestyle or
live a healthy vegan lifestyle you can
put a bikini on and not starve yourself
all day you do not need to earn your
meals yes eating fruits and vegetables
and exercising and going and laying on
the beach
and having massages that is all great
but bottom line balance and moderation
is the key so guys I hope you enjoyed
this review of what I eat in a day of
caralyn dessler's video if you did be
sure to give me the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with other youtubers that
you want me to review subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]